morning rishi
how do you follow an act like boris
johnson that's what the contenders for
the job of next british prime minister
are trying to work out
rishi sunak chancellor until last week
and one of those whose rebellion forced
johnson out looks like the front runner
he set the tone as he launched his bid
with a slick video
let me tell you a story
it details his indian grandparents
arrival in the uk via east africa
the video is high on emotion
perhaps to show his conservative party
colleagues that he can relate to voters
it's your stories that matter most
in the short term it's the conservative
party which will select the next leader
long term it's voters who will decide
some people are one big personality just
like boris other people are going to be
looking for someone who can stand on the
world stage so the conservative party
mps and conservative party members will
be thinking who's best place to win that
general election in two years time whose
personality can cut through to an
electorate that's often you know seen as
pretty disgruntled and disenfranchised
with uk politics after rishi sunak it's
a list of increasingly unknown
characters who are lining up to be
leader that could give the conservatives
the problem of how to reach voters who
are swayed just as much by boris
johnson's personality as they were by
his politics
among those confirmed are iraq war
veteran tom tuggenheart and attorney
general suella braverman
sunak was heir apparent to johnson for a
long time before his billionaire wife's
status as a non-taxpayer caused problems
for a man charged with handling the uk's
finances
but johnson often proved adept at moving
on from the mistakes he made in power
sunak will hope he can do the same
and replace his former boss
paul reese aljazeera london